What is your understanding of the use of cesium chloride for a eliminated cancer? I
would encourage to use cesium potassium, agaracus, vitamin D3, aspirin, coral
calcium, and selenium. Well, cesium chloride is an alternative cancer treatment
that I have talked about in my book. It's not something we'd use in the clinic
used two years ago. There's just too much risk. You have to really stay on top
of the patient in a communicative way. We communicate with them, you know, daily,
and then, you know, several times a week because it can have a side effect.
Cesium can be very toxic to the body and a person can get really sick. So we don't use cesium,
we don't sell cesium. There's just too much risk involved. Though there's people that, you know,
just like with any cancer treatment that have had great success with it. So that would be
something that you'd have to get somewhere else. Nothing wrong with using potassium. Nothing
wrong with using any type of mushrooms. Course D3. The aspirin issue, that's
something I would necessarily agree with. Coral calcium, I would totally not agree with. Coral
calcium comes from some belief many years ago, back in the, probably in the 80s or 90s, when
who was the doctor that wrote dead doctors, don't lie or something like that. I can't remember
when it was, had a cassette tape out. He really pushed minerals. There's so many things he said were
correct, except the whole issue about oral calcium. He claimed that he got this calcium from
someplace in Japan of these people. This was a blues old. These people lived longer because they
were consuming coral calcium. I think there's just completely wrong falsified information. Coral calcium
is calcium carbonate. But if you listen to any of my talks on minerals, you want to be eating minerals
that are from a plant source. And you don't eat minerals from a soil source. Calcium carbonate,
you know, there's, there's tons of studies that show consuming calcium carbonate,
increases calcium deposits on the arteries in the endothelial cells. You end up with heartening
in the arteries. You end up getting calcium deposited in the joint capsules causing arthritis
and in the ligaments causing tendonitis. Calcium carbonate is eating limestone. That's what limestone
is. Calcium carbonate. Coral calcium is limestone. Period. It's just not good for you.
Really, really poor source of calcium. I wouldn't recommend anybody consume calcium carbonate.
You take calcium from a plant source, which is going to be a double bond to an amino acid. That's
what plants do. They take calcium carbonate and they change it to calcium that has a double bond to
an amino acid. That's how you would take your any of your minerals. All your minerals should be
double bond into an amino acid. That's a keylation to an amino acid. But you get them in different forms.
You can get magnesium glycidate. That's magnesium double bond into a glycine amino acid, malate,
magnesium malate. You can get them in different forms. The two companies that have the pattern on
double bonded minerals to an amino acid is the tracks company TRAACS. I forgot the other name
of the other company. I think they're actually one company now. All the good supplement companies
buy their minerals from them. All the good supplement companies buy the minerals from them. All the
supplements that we sell are in that form. There are some whole food nutrition that just get
the the minerals from the plant source itself and that might be in the form of calcium or magnesium
lactate.